it's great to be joined today by Bill
Oglesby who's an assistant professor at
Virginia Commonwealth University's
Robertson School of Media and culture
also the producer and director of
jerry-rigged turning democracy on its
head a documentary produced by community
idea stations in cooperation with the
public interest group one virginia 2021
which is working on issues of
redistricting bill it's so great to have
you on let's just start at the most
basic point which is when we talk about
gerrymandering what are we talking about
gerrymandering is very simply the
drawing of political lines for a
partisan purpose usually by the very
people who are who tend to be to benefit
from those those lines being drawn that
way and when we're talking about
elections in a presidential election
gerrymandering is is much less relevant
than when we look at the makeup of the
US House of Representatives can you talk
about that a little bit yeah well of
course in in presidential elections
we're dealing with we're dealing with
generally a winner-take-all kind of
situation in all but two states where
the the person getting the most votes
takes all of the electoral votes course
that the Electoral College is another
issue in Maine and Nebraska they have it
the votes distributed according to as I
understand it the House of
Representatives the house congressional
districts that could be affected by
gerrymandering because House districts
are the Senate of course the US Senate
not so much either because you have two
US senators and they're elected
statewide so there's no blinds to be
drawn so gerrymander it's not an issue
there where we find gerrymandering isn't
really an issue are in the state
legislatures and in the US House of
Representatives and in the documentary
again it Virginia is a big deal when it
comes to gerrymandering it was actually
the Virginia Governor Patrick Henry who
was the first to sort of redistricting
his favor even though the name
gerrymandering is actually because of
our a former governor in Massachusetts
Elbridge Gerry so talk a little bit
about how this started when it started
and then how it became something that's
just so common today yeah well of course
that's nice of you to bring that up
because that's a big deal here in
Virginia but we're always sort of vying
with Massachusetts a little bit for this
is me Henry Amanda really yes exactly
well and the reason I think it was not
called Henry mattering was it didn't
work for Patrick Henry he tried it
basically in 1788 what he was trying to
do was he actually had a political feud
sort of going on with future President
James Madison and so what he did was he
redistricting so that James Madison's
home would be in the same district with
James Monroe another future president
thinking that that would surely mean
that James Madison would lose
unfortunately for him it didn't work and
James Madison won anyway so that's
probably why it didn't get he didn't get
quite as much notoriety from Henry man
during as later Elbridge Gerry in
Massachusetts and I don't know why I
think his name was pronounced Gary and
it's gerrymandering usually but this was
in 1812 a few years later and he drew a
district that was said to resemble a
salamander it was so unusual with the
lines being drawn and that's how we came
up with the term gerrymandering so it's
in the logistics of it a little bit I
think if you say to someone well you can
draw the districts in a way that's
advantageous for one party or another it
might not be completely self-evident the
sort of mathematics and logistics of how
that works right well basically of
course the the census is taken every 10
years and the the first year of the
decade so the next one will be the last
one was in 2010 the next will be in 2020
the year after that when we have all of
the figures from the census that's when
lines are redrawn because we need to
have as part of the one-person one-vote
system we need to have districts that
are approximately equal in population so
as the population
changes every 10 years you need to
redraw those district lines and it is
generally the state legislature that's
drawing those district lines and so
they're drawing it for themselves
they're also drawing it for the the
House of Representatives so they can
draw the lines in such a way that they
benefit one particular party over
another and I do want to emphasize that
both parties have been equally guilty of
this when they've been in power it just
depends which one is in power at any
given time and we do see in the United
States today we're on a state
state-by-state basis states where
Republicans are stronger they tend to be
drawing the lines to benefit Republicans
and in states where Democrats are
stronger they draw them to benefit
Democrats and one of these so as an
example you could imagine a hypothetical
state with 60% Democrats and 40%
Republicans and if that that would sort
of lead you to think that if you had a
fair drawing of the districts roughly
60% of the House seats would end up held
by Democrats and 40% held by Republicans
talk to us about how you can draw
districts such that you would not end up
with that ratio well it's actually
what's made gerrymandering such a
problem today as opposed to 200 years
ago is that we have computer software
that can do it in a remarkably efficient
way literally they can no and and and of
course that gets down to all of the
information that can be collected on
people through marketing efforts and so
forth on the on the internet we can know
what kinds of magazines people subscribe
to we can know all sorts of things that
that tell us this person is more likely
a Democrat this person is more likely a
Republican and these two computer
programs can literally draw lines around
houses down streets ignoring blocks in
such a way that they basically ensure
that the person who represents that
district is not going to have
significant opposition from the other
party
and that's not good for society it it
leads to a case where has it's been said
many times the voter the politicians are
choosing the voters rather than the
voters choosing the politicians and that
is to a great extent happening because
of this very sophisticated computer
software that uses very sophisticated
algorithms to do its job so in our
imaginary 60% Democratic 40% Republican
state you could take those 60% Democrats
and cram them into some smaller
percentage of the districts which would
still have in the popular vote maybe for
these House seats 60% of the votes going
to Democrats but you would end up with
far fewer than 60% of the seats held by
Democrats that's generally the idea
isn't is it not yes and it gets a little
more complicated because you know if you
think about it the only way that you
would end up with a perfect 60/40 split
in the scenario you came up with is if
those people were distributed pretty
equally right
if the geography of the state went but
what happens is and this is one of the
arguments that's used against
redistricting reform is when you have
certain urban areas we're tending to
live around like-minded people so we
tend to have urban areas where Democrats
concentrate and rural areas where
Republicans concentrate those rural
areas are more spread out so in a lot of
those democratic urban districts you're
not going to have a 60/40 Democratic
split you're going to have perhaps a
seventy seventy-five percent democratic
base and so that's going to be fewer
Democrats in other districts so it
doesn't create a perfect situation here
in Virginia we've had statewide
Democratic officials elected
consistently through this decade we
haven't had a Republican statewide
official elected since 2009 and yet our
House of Delegates is two-thirds
Republican sixty-six seats out of 100
you eluded you alluded to big data being
able to tell us based on different
characteristics that
when someone might have whether they're
more likely to be a democratic or
republican voter one of these indicators
mathematically speaking is also race and
courts have ruled that racial
gerrymandering is unconstitutional but
how can you draw the line as to what
constitutes definitive racial
gerrymandering versus tying districts to
some other characteristics that
underlying that certainly race may still
persist I mean it seems like a very
complex gray area does it not well it is
and what they have to do is they have to
try to measure intent to look at what
the intent of the legislature is because
under the Voting Rights Act we actually
want to have some majority minority
districts so that we encourage the
ability for minorities to be elected to
Congress and so forth but what happens
is you're not supposed to be able to
take the racial data in order to pack
districts we have a situation where
what's happened is because there's a
perception that that the minority voters
are more likely to do the Democrat what
Republican legislators are doing is
they're packing as many minorities into
that one Democratic majority minority
district as possible more than they need
to and what that does is that assures
that the three or four districts that
surround it are going to go Republican
so that that's what happens in in a
packing situation so the idea is that
yes in and under the Voting Rights Act
for a very laudable goal you are
supposed to take race into account to
some extent but it's not supposed to be
your primary factor let me remind you
we've been speaking with Bill Oglesby
who's an assistant professor at Virginia
Commonwealth University also the
producer and director of the documentary
jerry-rigged turning democracy on its
head let's pause there we're gonna pick
it up tomorrow
with Bill and talk about how bad is
national gerrymandering at this point in
the United States thanks so much bill
thank you David
continuing with us on the program today
is Bill Oglesby he's an assistant
professor at Virginia Commonwealth
universities Robertson School of Media
and Culture also the producer and
director of the documentary film
jerry-rigged turning democracy on its
head bill yesterday we left off after
talking about sort of figuring out what
is gerrymandering political
redistricting some of the strategies
that are used how can we or can we
measure how bad national gerrymandering
is right now and what sorts of data can
we look at to inform ourselves about
that well we know it's bad because what
we have is the parties have gotten smart
back in 2010 the Republican Party which
was reeling from the election of Barack
Obama and of course initially had
Democratic control of the Congress at
that point that means that the Democrats
were intro of the control of the agenda
and the Republicans were panicking to
some extent but you have to give them
credit what they did was they looked at
a national map they looked at at every
state at districts across those states
and they very very strategically
targeted certain districts within each
state that were vulnerable and in those
districts they put a tremendous infusion
of money on a national basis it ended up
being not as expensive as it would sound
for them it was just that they were very
strategic in the way they put the money
into those districts and it succeeded in
turning over the state legislators in
large numbers of states to Republican
control and that meant the next year the
Republicans were in charge of the
redistricting agenda and that's why we
have a situation now where we have so
many non-competitive districts as an
example a couple of years ago with 435
members of the House of Representatives
only only a handful of districts were
competitive and only I think seven
districts out of 435 were considered to
be toss-ups that's how well they've done
with that is there a mathematical
analysis that can be done which would
say that if we had fair districting the
odds that you would have only seven
toss-ups out of 435 seats are some I
would imagine in
credibly small number outside the
possibility of just average chance does
such data exist oh absolutely I mean
you've got to be able to you know the
same the same data that allows you to
draw districts so that so that each and
every in most cases district becomes
uncompetitive or non-competitive that
same data can be used to make districts
more compact which will in many cases
make them more competitive not in all
cases because you don't really want to
substitute one form of gerrymandering
for another it's really not the idea is
normally not to try to make every
district a competitive district it's
simply not to have the people who are in
in office controlling their own
reelection and controlling the lack of
competition they have I think it's
important to point out because a lot of
people don't really understand ibly
don't don't really know what what is
caused by gerrymandering but when you
when you have this lack of competition
it leads to voter apathy and that in
turn leads to a lack of moderation if
I'm representing a certain district and
I'm not worried about a challenge from
the other party because they can't they
mathematically can't win in my district
what I am concerned about is a challenge
from within my own party which tends to
take me further to the left if I'm a
Democrat further to the right if I'm a
Republican we've got data that shows
that in in in cases where that has been
removed as a factor people tend to move
more toward the middle there's more
moderation but this all the situation we
have now is leading to the kind of hyper
partisanship and gridlock that we're all
seeing on certainly the national level
and in many cases the state level not
only that I mean we also know that when
when voter turnout is depressed it tends
to help the candidate that's further to
the right and this applies between
Democrats and Republicans but also
within primaries with the more
conservative of the Democrats in a
primary the more conservative of the
Republicans in a primary and feeling
like there's no point to voting because
it's so non-competitive
would would only depress voter turnout
further as you're sort of pointing out
is there a number you could give us bill
like for example in order for Democrats
to win 50% of House seats nationally
they would need to get X percent of the
total number of votes that might
illuminate how skewed the situation is
yeah I don't have that exact number but
you're right it would take more than 50
because it would you know we do have a
situation again where you do have you do
have living patterns such that you you
can't you know even if you have compact
contiguous districts which is what is
required in most states and and and
certainly would would lead to more
greater communities of interest which is
what we're altima trying for but because
of voting patterns or living patterns
rather it's not a perfect system so you
do have to live you you do have to allow
for that I think in Virginia for
instance even though we are statewide
Democrats are appear to be at an
advantage if we had if we had that
perfect system where we removed
gerrymandering as a as a factor we would
probably still have Republican control
in our House of Delegates for instance
it would probably be fifty five out of a
hundred rather than 66 out of a hundred
though major difference no doubt about
it when you're talking about breaking
gridlock and passing bills let's talk a
little bit about other ways that this
could be done California passed
Proposition 11 which put issues of
redistricting into the hands of a
nonpartisan Commission back in 2008 is
that a good strategy what other
strategies exist and how can the average
voter get involved in this right many
many many states are looking at
independent redistricting commissions
and I think that's I think that's
important now they take many different
forms in California they have a system
where virtually anybody can can apply to
be on that commish
California has a strong as many Western
states do a very strong kind of voter
initiative kind of system and that
probably led since that's how
proposition 11 was passed that led to
them being the leader in this also
another thing they have out in
California that's worth mentioning that
would be very very difficult in a state
that doesn't have voter initiative is
they have their top to finish or
primaries where instead of having a
separate Republican and Democratic
primary you have one primary everybody
runs in that primary and the top two
finishers go on to meet in the general
election sometimes those top two
finishers are gonna both be Democrats
sometimes they're going to both be
Republicans but they're both going to
have to appeal to the middle or the
successful one is going to be the one
that tends to appeal to the middle so
that's what has had a big effect in
moderating out there in other states you
know in Virginia the the the the one
we're talking about the system we're
talking about right now would be where
you would have some a commission with a
couple of Democrats a couple of
Republicans but there would also be
three members that would be nonpartisan
state officials sort of like the
executive director of the Virginia State
Bar who's not considered to be a
Republican or a Democrat doesn't mean
they don't have opinions obviously but
they are not that they are used to
playing nonpartisan roles and the idea
also being that whatever whatever plan
they put forward that they come up with
and put forward has to have a
supermajority so it if we had that kind
of commission and both Republicans or
both Democrats opposed the plan that was
put forward it could not go forward they
would have to have it wouldn't have to
have at least bipartisan support so bill
or so you know a couple years out now
from the Census and then after that we
will have the redistricting at what
point and in what ways can individuals
who care about this issue get involved
be it with the census or whether the
with the actual districting process in
their state to have an impact here good
question or the thing
we're finding that of course is really
important is for people to care enough
to call their representatives and their
senators as well because the state
Senate even though they you know the
state Senate is is subject to this as
well they you know let them know that
you care they tend to realize that the
the issues that people are most likely
to call them about are ones that involve
their taxes or involve their children's
or their children or their schools they
don't think people care about
redistricting but as people come to
understand just the damaging effects
that are happening because of
redistricting in a gerrymandered way
people are getting involved they're
calling their representatives and they
need to do that so it becomes an issue
and and it really is a good government
issue
even in Virginia former governor and
senator George Allen a Republican who
was a victim of gerrymandering when he
was in the US House at the hands of a
Democratic state legislature he has
called it ridiculous and said reform is
needed so that's what people need to do
is let their representatives know it's
being attacked on a number of fronts
it's being attacked in the Legislature's
it's gerrymandering is being attacked
through in some cases voter initiative
when that's available in the courts we
have a we have significant cases that
are coming one that's coming up very
soon before the Supreme Court that could
have a a fact or an effect across the
board across the United States and how
these districts are drawn and in as a
result who gets elected the documentary
is jerry-rigged
turning democracy on its head we've been
speaking with the film's producer and
director Bill Oglesby who's also an
assistant professor at Virginia
Commonwealth University's Robertson
School of Media and culture bill
super-interesting important and an issue
we're going to be staying on so thank
you so much for talking to us about it I
appreciate you doing that David thank
you it's been good talking with you